hey guys Pete here gonna make a short
preview video today about Game of
Thrones season 7 episode 4 going to talk
about Theon and Jon we finally got this
image in the trailer of fian landing
back at Dragonstone so we're going to
talk about that it was actually working
on a different video but I saw someone
had tagged my facebook page with the
photo it was a spoilery photo from when
they were filming in Spain and it was
kind of messed up all the way around it
said it showed the photo which I had
seen before but in the description it
said John kills Theon in the next
episode and I deleted the photo so I
can't remember exactly but something to
the effect of tag someone you want to
ruin it for so it was like a spoiler
that people were spreading around and I
you know I don't believe that that's
true nothing about John and his story
makes it seem like that's something he
might do is just kill Theon for no
reason I mean he has real reasons to be
upset with beyond but I just don't see
him especially as a guest at Dragonstone
just killing him for some reason and
then we could look at the more logical
at you know aspects of this that he
turned in his weapons and so on and so
forth but yeah I thought that was really
messed up thing if I hadn't seen the
photo already I would have been really
kind of pissed off and yeah I'd like I
said I don't think that that's actually
going to happen but I am curious as to
what will happen when Theon arrives
since John is likely still there so if
you haven't been you know rewatching or
you kind of forgot about si on pre his
captivity with Ramsay he definitely sold
out the stark family during the war Robb
sent him over to his home at Pike in the
iron island so that he could talk to his
father Balon Greyjoy because he needed
ships basically and when he got there as
father basically treated him like dirt
he told him that he didn't want to have
anything to do with this and eventually
Theon decided that he was more loyal to
his own family than he was to rob to
make everything really simple then
you'll remember that he went he was
given
a small task to Punk him by his dad
compared to Yara who his dad obviously
favored to go and raid some islands and
some small busywork kind of stuff is the
way he took it then he gets an idea that
he could use what he knows about
Winterfell since he was there as a ward
for his whole childhood and grew up with
rather than the other stark boys and
their family and he ends up taking
Winterfell in the process of that he get
seduced by Asha and that makes it
possible for bran and Rickon to get out
of there his men who he had a hard time
getting behind him in the first place
kind of blame him for this and it was
pretty much his fault when you think
about it but anyways they end up killing
a couple farm boys and burning their
bodies and presenting that as Brandon
Rickon to kind of keep everybody in line
he sends for reinforcements to Yara
she realizes it's a terrible idea what
he's done and there's no real reason the
whole winter fell so she comes tries to
talk him into leaving he doesn't want to
give up the prize more or less I guess
you would say and then eventually he
ends up captured by Ramsay and we all
know what happened at that point where
he spends quite a long time being a
captive getting tortured in unimaginable
ways and eventually a spirits broke to
the point that later whenever Yara comes
to try to free him he's so afraid he
won't even leave he'd rather stay there
and be reek
it is absolutely terrible what happens
to him in the show but it's even a lot
worse when you read about it in the
books like it was a very tough tough
time and I think you get the idea from
the show but I mean it's definitely like
haunting when you read the actual Theon
stuff when he was with Ramsay there
overtime you know he gets conditioned
Ramsay uses them to get moat Cailin and
once they're in Winterfell and sanso
comes back after she's Wed to Ramsay
he eventually snaps out of it enough to
help her escape and you remember when
they were out there he realizes how Jon
will probably kill him well that's what
he thinks going to
sunson says they she'll say well they
you know you're getting really killed
bran and Rickon but it doesn't matter in
his mind because everything else he's
done there's just no way that John would
ever forgive him so that's the setup
Fiona now is on the outs of his own men
for not sacrificing himself in battle to
save Yara so he's coming in to
Dragonstone with his tail between his
legs he doesn't really have anything to
offer anyone at this point because the
iron fleet's been destroyed and he's
going to run into John who has cause to
be upset with to him to save the lead he
does have that redeeming thing that he
helps taunt to escape and this is going
to play a part but what do we think is
really going to happen between these two
jion's passing the story is a pretty
interesting one when you look at it as a
whole I mean he was pretty unlikable for
a lot of reasons and then he became a
sympathetic character whenever he was
going through all that horrible stuff
with Ramsay and then at the end he kind
of got it back and he saved Sansa Yara
never really lost hope in him and she
was right to the very end right before
the battle at seat started was trying to
prop him up to bring him back to who he
once was so he looked like he was on
this redemptive art but then he ends up
going back to Dragonstone with his
sister being a captive so there is that
idea that he could save her from his
uncle I never really thought too much
about this as being his purpose in the
overall story though so my idea has been
for a while that he's going to end up
being important and his Redemption is
going to come probably by the cost of
his life and something that he does for
John like we've seen him over the last
season especially just how eat down he
is and I mean you know it's not his
existence is a painful one and I think
Alfie Allen does a great job of this I
mean he you know you feel that he's a
character that is just struggling to
find something to live for so yeah
that's what I think will happen I think
that John will be angry with him at
first
and then possibly just by the fact that
John's there by himself with only Davos
for the most part he'll probably come
around to him
we know from episode three that John's
going to be able to mind some
dragonglass there I can't really imagine
how Theon has some special skill
involved in that but I think he'll end
up going back with John when John goes I
mean that could go two different ways he
could head north of the wall with John
when we see all that footage they kind
of kept that so that we don't see who's
there with him we've seen that barracks
there or he could be the one that goes
to Winterfell that splits off with them
and goes to Winterfell to tell everybody
up there what's going on or whatever I
don't know I think there's something big
in beyond future I don't know what it is
I'd be real interested to see what you
guys think about I'm very excited about
seeing that I'm excited about seeing
these two characters together they have
not been for quite some time
and it's kind of interesting because you
got descent in the beginning that since
Theon was a ward and he didn't really
belong he kind of picked on John a bit
because at least he wasn't a bastard you
know what I mean and Rob did kind of
favor
Theon because they were a little bit
closer so I don't know it should be
interesting let me know what you guys
think please like the video if you
enjoyed it let me know if you saw that
crafty post that someone was spreading
around and if it spoiled things for you
make sure you follow me on Twitter at my
other social media accounts and thanks
for watching I'll talk to you soon
you
you